hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from yesterday's
aimchess us rapper preliminaries it's uh
the leader of uh of the tournament after
two days vladislav artemia vs levon
arunyan and it's quite an interesting
game so uh let's check it out and then
we're gonna check out the standings as
we usually do after checking out at
least three games from the tournament so
artemiev with the white pieces opens
with d4 we have knight to f6 c for e6
knight to f3 and d5 now the queen's
gambit declined this on the board we
have knight to c3 and bishop to b4 uh
arunan goes for the ira goes in defense
with e3 and now uh striking in the
center with c5 uh c captures on the e5
we have knight captures on d5 and now
bishop to d2 adding another defender to
the c3 knight we have castles by black
and now bishop to d3 now just continuing
development we have knight to c6 and
here uh castle's king side
and now there are a few games where b6
was played and also c characters on d4
is a known move but here we have knight
back to f6 by levon and it is not uh
already as of move nine that we have a
completely new game uh so let's see how
uh artemis deals with this with a3 uh
challenges the bishop on b4 c captures
on d for e captures on d4 and now bishop
back to e7
we have bishop to e3 now adding another
defender to the pawn here uh and uh b6
now black wants to find his own light
square bishop uh we have queen to e2 uh
connecting the rooks now the rooks can
be developed let's say rook c1 rook d1
uh and bishop to b7
uh the bishop is now on this very nice
diagonal we have rook eight to d1
and rook the c8 by black we rook after
e1 and with this move artemia pretty
much finishes development uh levon still
has to develop the queen connect the
rooks and get the other rook into the
game so queen to c7
and now uh the queen no longer uh
attacks the d4 pawn so you don't need
the bishop on e3 so artemis grabs more
space with bishop to g5 uh we rook after
d8 and now bishop back to b1 so now both
of these uh
pieces are defending the d4 pawn uh and
now knight the a5 this knight can now
come to b3 also maybe the c4 the queen
and rook are nicely guarding that square
and by placing the knight on a5 you open
up this uh
long a light square diagonal for the
bishop and here knight the e5 grabbing
this central square made possible by the
absence of the knight from c6 uh and now
what do you do here it's a it's a very
tricky position but uh
just going to c4 blunders the game uh so
you don't want to do this and uh levon
did not play this because after knight
b5 the queen cannot remain here
defending this knight and you simply
lose a piece queen has to move we're
going to pick up the knight and wrap a
piece but the move levon played isn't
much better he played queen to d6 and
this is uh
just a dead lost for for black uh so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this
most interesting refutation from white
uh while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding either of
these two very interesting ideas it's
either bishop captures on f6 or d5
bishop captures on f6 is a more of a
brute force approach and it is what uh
artemis played but i'm going to show d5
as it's well just really really
interesting so
what can bla black do here it doesn't
really matter because absolutely
everything loses so we're just going to
show the the the main line e captures on
d5 and now we're going to go for knight
to b5 the queen on d6 also uh in reach
of the knight so now after the queen
moves we play knight d4 attack the queen
queen to d6 and now uh the move you guys
wanted to play uh for for so long knight
captures on f7 attacks the queen and the
rook and after the king captures now the
other knight comes to f5 with an attack
on the queen and now we have a triple
attack on the bishop here uh queen's
gonna move now we're gonna catch on e7
and it doesn't matter what you play here
if rook to e8 pinning the knight just
bishop captures an f6 g captures we're
gonna go queen to h5 check and you will
get checkmated king to f8 queen h6 check
king to f7 queen captures king to f8 and
now king to f8 and unknight the g6 will
be checkmate so just uh
one of the fun lines that could uh
happen if uh here for example d5 is
played but bishop captures on f6 is also
winning this is what artemis played and
it features a capture and a sacrifice so
bishop captures on f6 and now bishop
captures an h7 and you can't capture
this bishop if you capture it then queen
to h5 check goes after the f7 pawn king
g8 queen captures an f7 and after king
h7 rook to e3 there's no defense uh
you're just getting destroyed here
uh so after this bishop captures an h7
we have king to f8 by levon and now
queen the h5 just going for that
checkmate not caring about about
anything uh and you can't go for
captures uh captures and queen captures
and d1 because well it's just the
defended by the knight by the queen by
the rook so for the moment this is not
possible uh but you could go for bishop
captures an e5d captures and queen to c5
trying to get out of mate this way but
then we have this bishop to g6 idea and
it's just uh just ugly uh for example
captures queen to h8 queen to f7 and now
we capture here and the queen also helps
out here captures captures and the white
is just now well up too much material
and completely winning not much you can
do here i've queen to c6 you want to
threaten checkmate it's not a problem we
can simply block it knights to e4 going
to d6 with check uh black black is just
lost here so after queen to h5 we have
rook to c7 just adding a defender to the
f7 pawn and now bishop back to e4
clearing up the dh8 square for the queen
so
now you have to decide what to do we
have bishop to a6 not interested in this
trade and now bishop back to b1 before
before going to queen the h8 to check
and this is a very nice idea yeah if you
go queen to h check right away then king
to e7 and it doesn't seem like there's
all that much uh to be done here if
queen to h5 black could you know prolong
the the defense with with rook to f8
white is still better but uh maybe you
know it's a rapid game
you don't want to give him too much
chances uh so after bishop to a6 we have
bishop to b1 uh and now comes g6 and
this is just uh
just a there you know do you capture
this or not and of course artemis
captured this so bishop captures ng6 f
captures knight captures on g6 would
check king to g7 and now knight to e4
attacking the queen here so queen to d5
offering a queen trade and now you can
try playing this in many different ways
knights to e5 is one
nice way
because well even if this is captured
you don't really gain anything you can't
deliver checkmate because the queen also
covers the rook here and black is just
getting destroyed here there's really no
good way of of playing this uh but
artemis chooses a different way he plays
knight to f4 attacks the queen defends
his own queen uh levon traits here we
have captures captures with king f7 and
now knight h captures on f6 so he goes
into the same game wins back his piece
and now he's up three pawns and it's
going to be very hard to stop them
we have rook to c2 now uh going after
that b2 pawn putting a rook on a very
active second rank and now just the d5
completely merciless uh we have e
captures knight captures and now finally
this knight joins the game with knight
the c6 but now it is much too late so
knights the g5 check king to g6 and now
knight the e6 attacking blacks rook here
uh rook to h8 and now knight d to f4
with check we have king to f6 and now
rook to d6 threatening a lot of a lot of
nasty discoveries here so rook to e8 but
now uh our team you've just played
knight to d for check you could try
anything here but this is also perfectly
winning uh knight to d for chicken
knight the c7 check also very nice uh
andy was in this position on move 36
that levon ariana resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
you will not be checkmating white
because after the king moves for example
king f7 we're going to play knight
characters on c2 we're going to be
defending our rook here we're going to
be up a full rook so completely winning
for white
so very interesting game and very uh
very early things have gone wrong for
levon okay maybe not very early uh you
know it moves 17 but uh it was only a
new move at
move nine so you know not not a lot of
moves were actually played in this game
uh but very interesting line if you're a
fan of dragozin maybe maybe uh nice to
know uh this line
uh so uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said we're going to
show the standings have tmf is the
leader of the mhs preliminaries after
after two two days so here are the
standings so you can see uh the left
side of the standings are those who are
uh able to qualify for the main event
and to the right are those who will not
qualify if they remain on the right so
artemis leading the tournament with
seven and a half uh magnus cross and
levon are you on second place sharing
with seven with six and half chakra
moment of wesley and alireza with six uh
with five and a half young shisht of
duda and anish giri uh with five daniel
naradicki and maxine vashila graph four
and a half linear dominguez and v
gujarati uh with three uh jvf and liam
liam
and eric hansen and the wanderling with
two points so it's going to be very
interesting who can uh you know join uh
the
uh the leaders in the left part of the
table or who will remain on the right
we'll see but yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it always uh enjoyable
when chuck norris is doing well and uh
in the last round yesterday he faced
magnus carlsen magnus was trying to win
but uh he couldn't uh and uh uh a lot of
love
retained his lead uh so yeah once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank alan guyeta david kimura
vladimir mark thompson and annie mccain
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check to all my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of this very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day